We have a voicemail number, which is two one
nine two David P..
Here is yet another question about 20-20 and
Donald Trump.
A quick question.
Theoretically, I was now.
Yes.
From spend the next four years with his base
even more.
Could you run for president again until the
second term, four years later?
You legally do that within do so within our
borders?
Yes, you can.
So the question is, if Trump loses now and
Biden is president four years, could Trump
run in 2024?
He could.
I don't think he will.
I think if listen, if Trump loses, he is a
narcissist.
He will have to justify his loss.
He can't just say, I lost.
I lost because people didn't want me.
I lost because I messed up.
Trump was justified and say I didn't want
it any way.
Screw you guys.
I've got better things to do, et cetera.
Trump will be nearly 80 in 2024.
Trump is not going to run in 2024 if he loses.
This is it.
Okay.
This is the opportunity.
We can get Trump out and that will be it for
Donald Trump.
Now, Don Junior or Eric or Ivanka.
Who the hell knows?
That's another story.
We'll cross that bridge when we come to it.
But this is it.
If Trump is not president the next four years.
That is it for Trump's presidency.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
So many great stories.
I hope you'll join me on the bonus show.
And remember that you can get instant access
to that world famous bonus show by becoming
a member at join Pacman dot com.